and so alcohol has a lot of different
effects um the the journalist stephen
brown has called it a pharmacological
hand grenade it just kind of goes in and
starts hitting all the buttons at once
it's really it's a it's a messy drug um
so it is in various timings and ways it
simulates the effects of meth and
cocaine prozac
uh valium opium is doing all these
things and at various points as you as
your bac
increases but crucially and what's going
to be crucial for the story i'm telling
today
is that it depresses the prefrontal
cortex it depresses the motor cortex as
well which is why you shouldn't drive
and you have trouble speaking at a
certain point of inebriation but
crucially it's down regulating that that
part of our brain temporarily and and
the nice thing is it does it gently it
does it predictably and it does it with
pretty um uh short uh half-life you you
recover very quickly so it's actually a
brilliant technology for for taking the
pfc offline temporarily and what does
that give you gives you creativity
so this there's this association you see
across the world throughout history
of creative types artists writers poets
with alcohol you see it in ancient china
you see it in the ancient mideast you
see it in the present day this is not a
myth there actually is a very good
reason why alcohol is associated with
creativity in artists it's because it
actually does make us more creative by
down regulating the prefrontal cortex
now in terms of direct evidence of this
there's not a whole lot right now this
is a nice study i like by michael
andrews looking at correlation
he's taking advantage he's an economist
and he took advantage of this great
natural experiment american prohibition
so we tend to think of prohibition as
something that happened all at once at
the federal level just suddenly no one
america could drink and it wasn't like
that at all it actually took a really
long time to impose prohibition and it
was imposed piecemeal at the county
level so he was able to look at county
level data and what he was looking at
was patent applications as a as a proxy
for innovation and he could look at
patent applications at the county level
and what he saw is that when you impose
prohibition on a county patent
applications plunge
collective innovation plunges and then
it slowly recovers it took about three
years to get back to pre-prohibition
levels
he his hypothesis is speakeasies
this is why that happened so basically
prohibition comes in you can't drink
socially anymore
innovation goes down and it goes down
until people figure how to work around
and the workaround was figuring out a
new way to drink socially so social
drinking seems to be related to
innovation group innovation in this
sense there's also one nice direct study
that shows that this is actually not
just correlational it's causation that
if you take subjects and you give them a
real alcoholic drink as opposed to a
fake alcoholic drink they're more
creative and their creativity peaks at
about 0.08 so that's about when you have
a nice buzz on when you shouldn't
operate a motor vehicle but that seems
to be the spot where you still have
enough cognitive control to actually
think coherently and do things that are
useful but you've been loosened up the
the hold of the pfc has been loosened
upon you in a certain way
so creativity is one of the really
important functions
of alcohol
another strange thing about us compared
to other primates
is that we are communal we're dependent
on other people in a way that no other
primate is and to get anything useful
done we need to trust one another we
need to engage in long-term cooperative
tasks that require trust and when we
embark upon these tasks we run into
various types of cooperation dilemmas
and these go under different types of
names prisoners dilemma tragedy of the
commons
they have the same structure though
you get the best payoff if you trust and
you cooperate the problem is this is a
crucial part of the structure of these
dilemmas i don't know in advance whether
or not you're going to cooperate with me
and if you don't cooperate if you defect
as economists put it i'm screwed
i get zero you get a great payoff and so
for a rational self-interested agent in
a prisoner's dilemma game the only
strategy is to defect so everyone
defects and everybody gets that kind of
bummer mutual defection outcome in real
life people solve this all the time
we're constantly solving prisoners
dilemmas in our real life and we do it
because we're not rational
self-interested agents we're emotional
and we use emotions to help solve these
dilemmas we have emotions like honor
like loyalty like trust that allow us
that bind us to each other in a certain
way that prevent defections from
happening so emotions the economist
robert frank has a great book called
passions within reason where he explains
that these love and honor and these
things they're approximately irrational
so in in your actual psychology they're
not rational but they have this kind of
long-term rationality on an evolutionary
scale
so so we use these emotions and because
emotions help us cooperate we use them
as cues to know who's a good cooperator
and who's not so when we're deciding
whether or not to trust someone we look
at their emotional expressions this is
the safety net we have in cooperation
i meet you and you genuinely are happy
to meet you how do i know you're you're
genuinely happy because you have that
smile on the left and not the one on the
right the left one is a duchenne smile
completely different muscle system
not under typically under voluntary
control that's the smile you make when
you're
serving people in a restaurant or
something you have to be nice to them
we like the one of the left we don't
like the one on the right so we use
emotional displays as a way to know
whether or not to trust people
this this opens up this this possible
risk though that people could be faking
it
the soft spot here again is a prefrontal
cortex in order to lie in order to cheat
in order to calculate you need your
prefrontal cortex in top shape lying is
very difficult cognitively right you
have to keep in track in your mind both
what's true and what's what you're
telling the person you have to suppress
emotions that have to do with the false
thing that you're not telling them about
it's it's real you need your pfc in top
shape
what's also interesting is uh when the
pfc is in top shape we're not as good at
detecting lies and this seems to be
because we look at when we're
consciously focusing on detecting lies
we're not very good at it we look at the
wrong things it's only when we're
relaxed that we actually take in more
information
so let's target the prefrontal cortex
with what with our good old friend
alcohol
down regulates the prefrontal cortex it
makes us heart it makes it harder for us
to lie it makes us easier for us to
detect lies and it's also simultaneously
boosting some hormones like serotonin
that make us less likely to cheat so
it's it's enhancing these kind of
pro-social hormones in human beings so
this is why
you know when when people potentially
hostile adults meet and have to come to
some kind of agreement they shake hands
and they're showing i'm not carrying a
weapon
when you meet with someone and you do a
couple of shots
you're saying i no longer have a
prefrontal cortex i am cognitively
disarming
and putting my prefrontal cortex on the
table you can trust me this is why
from ancient china to ancient greece
alcohol is always at the center of
banquets of treaty negotiations anything
where you have people with potentially
differing interests having to agree on
something
all the way up to you know nixon told
his chinese counterpart if we drank
enough mao tai we could do anything
right this idea that if we just disarm
cognitively we can solve these problems
and people use this informally all the
time so a cocktail party a mixer you're
having to meet new people
you want to cognitively disarm so we're
simultaneously decreasing our
inhibitions and increasing these kind of
pro-social chemicals that help us like
each other like ourselves more and like
each other's more so alcohol plays this
really important tool
in helping people
bond and helping people cooperate this
is also why when when skype was invented
remember back then
um everyone predicted business travel
would disappear right why would you get
on a plane and fly to shanghai
if you could just you know skype with
these people to sign a contract and yet
people kept getting on planes and flying
to shanghai until the pandemic it took a
global pandemic to shut down business
travel and this is because if you're
going to enter into any kind of
significant deal with another group of
people you want to sit down and get
drunk with them and eat a meal with them
to get a sense of who they are for real
so this is one of the important
functions of alcohol
so in in drunk i walk through
these functional and important benefits
of alcohol but the important point is
that
you don't want to admit you don't want
to lose sight of the cost of alcohol
it's a dangerous substance
it's estimated that up to 15 percent of
the human population is prone to
alcoholism and if you have a tendency to
alcoholism you can't drink safely
so it's a dangerous substance it can
lead to all sorts of chaos
but the taste for alcohol has been
preserved in our species because there
are these countervailing benefits